zach wilson's pro day was on friday and
zach wilson uh looked pretty good chris
i i i don't remember your tweet from the
thing but i have a feeling
it it uh we're gonna see it here
the game is played on the field but what
we saw from zach wilson today there's no
comparison between his workout and
trevor lawrence's it was out of this
world awesome the degree of difficulty
of the workout was high
and he made so many high-level throws
the one that stands out for me and i
think it was his last throw of the day
when he's going cross-body
yeah running right to left right and
through a
laser i mean it was my home's throw and
you've been saying all along this guy
has aaron rodgers in mahomes qualities
he showed him off there it is sprinting
left
look at that throwing it right and
trevor lord's like i can't do that oh
they didn't say that he just said
sheesh yeah well lebron james line
trevor yeah
it's uh i mean yes that was a special
workout
and i know it's not yeah it's not 11 out
of 11 and real football
but still you know what we saw there
really was a quarterback that went i'm
going to put on a show
i'm going to show you guys that hey yeah
i could throw to the wide open receiver
you know the 10 yard core route and the
10 yard out route and do all that
but let me show you what i can do when
the game's on the line
or you know our team's not very good and
we don't have great pass protection our
people aren't open
let me show you that because hey i'm
going to be a top five pick and that's
most likely the situation
going to be in and let me show you what
i can do in all those situations where
hey the team fails us but look i still
can do
all of this type of stuff right and i
know listen there's a lot of
quarterbacks in football who can make
those type of throws and all of that
there's no doubt
but that that still we don't see that
type of
degree of difficulty or workouts laid
out like what we just
saw there if we did right i mean
if it was if it was that easy all
quarterbacks would do it
there is great pressure and having a
workout like this mike
with having this kind of degree of
difficulty throws
listen other quarterbacks if they did
this right and all of a sudden wait
i've made a no-look throw and i've run
to the the left and throwing a ball
across the field to the right
and oh now i'm fading away to the left
and no feet on the ground throwing a 40
yard corner out to the right
and you miss a few of those throws all
of a sudden
things compound and the workout's like
oh no i've missed five in a row
this kid's so good going no no i can do
this and i might miss
one but that's as bad as it's gonna get
i'm gonna hit all the other ones and do
that
i mean that was an awesome workout to
watch and blew me away
and showed really the high level talent
the kid has in his arm and his feet
and really just the explosive athlete he
is to go along with it
all the obsession over mechanics and
getting a good brace and moving your
hips and your body and all that stuff
and
remember we were at the super bowl a few
years ago and you had me you point with
your shoulder
yeah you follow through all the things
that you do to throw it right and then
you have a guy like zach wilson who's
like a patrick mahomes who can be
any arm angle any base one foot on the
ground
no feet on the ground making those
throws
all arm that's what's amazing and that's
what's special and that's why
chris i mean i look the jaguars know
what they're getting with trevor
lawrence they're happy with trevor
lawrence he's a great prospect but
if it's jaguars lawrence and wilson
jets what what a strange dotted line
between two franchises that otherwise
have nothing
in common that will have something in
common because
i think we're all going to pay close
attention to the development of lawrence
in jacksonville
and the development of wilson with the
jets if that's what the jets do and if
they don't it's going to be wilson in
san francisco no i mean you i mean
you're right it's going to be you know
again it's
we do this it's you know jameis winston
marcus mariota carson wentz jared goff
rg3 andrew luck you know ryan leaf
peyton manning
eli manning phillip rivers i mean yeah
they're going to be connected to a
degree there's no doubt about that
and hey again we think jacksonville's
going trevor lawrence
i i do think that workout the other day
by zach wilson makes them a little
uncomfortable because everybody
that that that is eye-popping you know
there's a reason
the nfl was a little you know up in
chatter and talking about that workout
because there's not many people who have
put on that type of show
with that degree of difficulty of throws
and things like that
and then passed it you know with flying
colors in the way he did where it wasn't
just like
oh wow that looked cool it was like oh
wow
that's special and look at the results
that go along with it
and you know mike he's too what you know
you talked about like the mechanics and
things like that
really what it is is when the mechanics
get
so good and they're so ingrained to you
and it's just part of your game it's
like steph curry right
hey i can stand here and make a
three-pointer all day i've mastered that
i know the exact mechanics to do it
every time
now let me move out five feet farther
wait let me do it off the dribble
let me do it when i'm taking a step to
the right and i step back and do it
and that's what you see from mahomes or
zach wilson or rogers they go wait i got
the normal thing
mastered now let me show you what i can
do off of that
and their ability to still create the
right mechanics with no feet on the
ground or do anything like that is
special and that's where
you know again zach wilson's special
special
i think he showed why for me is the best
quarterback in the draft and i gotta
think that the new york jets finally
just went
okay um work out wait no check no wait
erase the check
star star star that was amazing we found
our quarterback of the future
one of the realities of modern life is
there are too many damn things to choose
from and the best example that i can
point to
yeah all of the streaming platforms out
there peacock i gotta mention peacock
first
obviously netflix hulu disney plus all
the others paramount plus now on
what are you what are we going to watch
and even when you pick the platform to
peruse
you can spend an hour looking for
something to watch life gets complicated
when there's too many choices
i say that not because i've lost my mind
although i possibly have
is it possible urban meyer didn't go
personally to the byu workout to see
zach wilson
because he didn't want his mind
cluttered with doubt
about trevor lawrence that if he's
standing there
behind zach wilson mask on
nose out hovering over zach wilson and
hears that ball zinging right out of his
hand
and sees how he's moving and and he may
say to himself
am i are we sure we're taking the right
guy here oh thank you very much
but you know if you don't show up for
the zack wilson workout you never put
yourself in that dilemma chris well yeah
i mean hey
i hear you there conspiracy mike okay i
hear you all the way
i mean i i get it you know hey trevor
lawrence first of all like we just
talked about
that's the reason urban meyer took the
job he's huge in that part of the
country
he's also the safe pick you know it
would take incredible
guts cajones whatever okay i got it
tomato tomato it would take you know
big time guts to now take
zack wilson at number one there's no
doubt about that
but again i think there's something to
like what you're saying too
hey you watch that workout you know we
had what sam
uh sam weiss right is that his name from
the nfl network there
talking steve weiss excuse me thank you
steve
steve's at all these workouts not that
he's a quarterback expert
but he sees them all he was trying to
tell everybody with his microphone that
whoa this is different
the ball popping out of this guy's hand
is like it's eye-popping
like i've been to these workouts and i
haven't seen the ball explode out of a
guy's hand like i have here
wait this guy's fading away and through
a 67-yard post
you know with no feet on the on the
ground
you know it's that type of stuff daniel
jeremiah you hear him
you know he's chuckling about like oh
he's going to put on a show
oh i think here at the end he's gonna do
this and all that you know so
again this this talent of this kid
it it it pops out not only in this
workout but where i get excited is i go
wait
wait i saw this on film and now i see it
in the workout too
and that's where i get really excited to
go we could have something special here
with this kid
and you could have an aaron rodgers
green bay
you know matt lefleur type combination
with the jets and robert sala and
michael
four and i think that's got to excite
jets fans
six two and a tenth 214 pounds
hand size nine and a half inches
do you happen to remember chris let's
see how well you know your quarterbacks
yeah do you happen to remember the
statistics
comparable from patrick mahomes four
years ago oh
well i think the hand size is right
around nine and a half right
nine and a quarter yeah nine and a
quarter okay so there's smaller hands
than zach wilson
smaller hand the the day it doesn't
matter anymore the with the
hand thing the way these quarterbacks
now are gripping the football like we've
talked a little bit where they grip it
towards the high
end of the ball to where they basically
almost make it where
only one hand one finger is on the lace
or anything like that
and they get the small part of the ball
up there to where now it's almost like a
baseball in their hand
like hand size is overrated i don't know
what else to say to you
it's that that day is done just as is
being 6'5
235 and i'm a franchise quarterback
that's overrated too it's done it's over
with the lack of ability to hit the
quarterbacks and do that type of stuff
and these quarterbacks are so athletic
now too
and can move and get out of the harm's
way who gives a damn
you know people talk about his size as a
big thing
hey we see too many quarterbacks they're
smaller and they're they're still
drew brees just retired it's been 20
he's small he's not that big
you know and 214 pounds i hear this all
the time with zach wilson
trevor lawrence was 210 pounds so stop
making it a big thing
you know this kid's punny big enough and
i think he's
from what i've been told mike like
can windmill dunk reverse dunk
like that's where i'm a little feel i
wanted to see him run the 40 and do the
vertical because from what i've told him
by people in the nfl circles he could
have put up some really impressive
numbers there too and of course we got
to see a little bit of what he is on
that field the other day
he was six two and a tenth mahomes was
measured at 6-2 at the combine
in 2017 so wilson actually a little bit
taller now
mahomes was 225 at the combine
wilson 214
when you throw like that it just doesn't
matter how big you are it doesn't matter
how big your hand is
when you can do what we saw wilson do on
friday
right it doesn't matter and i really do
wonder
whether or not urban meyer specifically
stayed away because he doesn't want
his brain cluttered for the next five
weeks with doubt
that wilson may end up being the better
guy than trevor lawrence
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports